i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real
[Music]
it was
[Music]
chaos we [ __ ] up at all the other
dealers so now i'm this way completely
not facing the show
and then
look at that sign
so this will be the big marketing of the
day
so that's where we're at let's see if we
handle today better all right who's gary
me
like i don't like selling 10 000 cards
right because it's not 1984. 20. you
know
how cool is this
now everybody can man it
i created an nft project my concept was
to build an intellectual property if you
think about the 1980s when cartoons came
out transformers he-man my little pony
they used cartoons to build awareness a
brand and then it became a
billion-dollar franchise when i saw the
nft thing happen and i understood what
it was one of the first things i said is
[ __ ] if george lucas had this when he
invented star wars and minted all of
star wars
think about how much star wars stuff is
gonna be sold here george lucas makes
zero nfts are our point zero one
awareness right now it's gonna take a
decade so in between i'm building up the
ip toy deals
animation shows and of course trading
cards
is peter here he's right there
what's up what's up how are you doing
it's coming right now literally like in
the last days of the process can you
guys drop it off then 100 yeah
i love you
have a good show brother
i like them on time i don't want to
waste the time
i'm very focused today i i can't have a
replication of yesterday so i'm locked
in
oh it says singing
guys i'll be singing
i like
want to
inspire like the world
at scale with kindness and stuff like
that like the way that you do it good
and like i listen to like
the dailyvee every morning like the
first book i've ever read garyvee
there's a twenty twelve and a half
audiobook like
talking
with guy kawasaki about getting as close
to the source yes
how do i do that
you sent me an email
friday night and say we've been hanging
out you know who i am
i want an internship here's what i think
i'm good at here's what i think i'm bad
at i'll give it a real look okay i mean
so much holy [ __ ] you have that no we
know the guys
what do they want they came in our shop
holy [ __ ]
yeah i saw him on twitter
[Music]
two three four months we're gonna start
announcing major tournaments with
major prizes and all of a sudden high
scores and high individual scores are
going to matter because there's
variations of the game that nobody knows
yet obviously you guys know which
characters matter yeah but if you look
carefully when you look through it later
like some of the scores don't match so
now it becomes like interesting like
it's like wait if this game takes off
is the nft super underpriced because
yeah it's like it's like all fun [ __ ]
yeah let's be friends
saving the world whoa you're gary vee
that's gary what the [ __ ] we're here you
made a millionaire bro
you made yourself a millionaire 2017.
club challenge i started consuming your
content thank you brother took me three
years dude proud
i know you're a hunter i live for it i
can't guarantee dude
right i'm so nervous
all right
my man good luck my man
macho is good
responsive rims by the way a bunch of uh
la rams are collecting responsive ram
nice wombat
turn tick up to five
dude you know what that is right uno
unicorn which is less than that one yeah
just went for 4 800 on ebay raw yeah
that's your [ __ ] monster
raw raw question my wife really looks up
to you
what's her name
abby you mind if i take a video i'm
gonna make a video i will
abby i'm here with your amazing wife we
miss you i can't wait to see you in
person too
come to vidcon come to the next card
show we need to say hello
love you keep going it always gets
better all right rolling camera all
right so i know you collect a lot of
cards would you do me a favor and pick
out your favorite three cards that you
have with you today
juan soto
rookie auto premium card 2700 akeem nine
still think one of the most underrated
break cards in the sport
and jerry west
psa six rookie card the logo
all right nice choices thank you
thank you
i like that
caught my attention
how much i sell it for me hold on to it
if you're willing to hold on for five
years hold on i'm a musician and i'm a
data analyst but i'm an extreme doctor
why i don't like data analytics i don't
like computer science in general so
don't do it
but the only problem is the visa status
every day i wake up it's it's extreme
pain well then you should go back those
are not the two worst options in the
world yeah you understand
you're an extreme darkness because you
don't have the perspective of
understanding that that is not as bad as
you think i get it i get it it sucks to
do something you don't like
but you've got options
you know one thing i just absolutely
recognized here at the national is how
much love i have for all the [ __ ]
breakers out there that are just [ __ ]
going out so hard building their
audiences trying to entertain trying to
educate
so just a random [ __ ] shout out to
all the [ __ ] breakers
out there
in sports car land got a lot of love for
you keep [ __ ]
grinding keep going cheering for you
you